scott perry the aforementioned
congressman from pennsylvania joins us
right now for his first exclusive
interview since the fbi confiscated his
phone congressman thanks for joining us
can you bring us through what happened
well brian you're actually absolutely
right i got a knock on the door
uh in the morning i went to the door
there are three fbi agents of course
like you said i'm traveling with my
family uh we have two young daughters
i'm with my uh my elderly in-laws and uh
you know they they want to take my cell
phone and
and i said you know could you contact my
attorney you know why
why does this have to happen you know
out on the street you know and how did
you find me by the way of course they
wouldn't answer that question
they said they were going to image the
cell phone and return it sometime later
since i didn't have a phone and this is
my personal cell phone brian i have a
you know i have a
a a a official cell phone they don't
they don't want that so this is my
personal cell phone that i talk to my
wife on that i talk to my children on my
constituents none of the government's
business
you know and of course immediately the
story blows up i'm sure you know and you
know what's interesting though is is
while that story blew up i heard from my
attorneys who talked directly to the
department of justice who said that i
their client am not a target of this
investigation now think about that if
i'm not a target why do they come follow
me you know find me on when i'm
traveling with my family they don't come
to my house they don't contact my
attorney
why did they come and seize my cell
phone to image it
in in that fashion if they would have
just caught contacted my attorney
certainly we would have provided the
information necessary as required by law
and that would have been the end of it
but they want this spectacle they want
this show they want the intimidation and
of course the media is not saying
anything about the fact that you know
reported today that i am not a target of
the of this investigation and so look
this is this is the doj run amok and i
think what people need to really think
about is in about a day we're going to
vote on a package and it'll probably
pass where they're going to employ 87
000 new irs agents what do you think
they're going to be doing they're being
they're going to be coming for all of
you you know
yesterday it was my cell phone tomorrow
it's going to be it's going to be
average hard-working americans that are
just trying to make it through their
days when did they confront you what day
uh yesterday what was yesterday was
tuesday tuesday morning now the
president's house was raided monday do
you think they're linked
right
i do i think all of this is linked of
course it is
and what do you think they're looking
for
look i i don't know like i said we asked
i'm not a target of the investigation so
i i can't really speculate
i don't know what they're looking for
but they came and and took my cell phone
even though i'm not a target which is so
think about that obviously if somebody
congressman this is what i'm getting at
the the national art they the fbi said
although the trump family has not seen
the uh the warrant yet
the fbi said
we're here for the on behalf of the
national archives okay
so the national archives or is this
about january 6th what do you think
boy here's what i think i think that
they're scared to death that president
donald trump is going to come back in
2024 and win reelection and they're
going to do every single thing that they
can to make sure that doesn't happen
including make up some kind of charges
from the national archives i mean quite
honestly it's absurd uh if it's the
national archives i mean the president
is the ultimate classification authority
you know saying he took classified
information out you know uh he's the
classifier james comey elite classified
information to get a a special counsel
hillary clinton well you know we don't
know the extent of the classified
information she had on her private
server no accountability whatsoever but
somehow do they think that president
trump packed the boxes at the white
house to take to mar-a-lago you know i
think this is all about 2024 and and
their disdain for president trump and
the fact that they know he's coming back
and likely to beat their candidate joe
biden did you or any other candidate did
you get your phone back
did you get your phone back
congressman did you get your phone back
i guess we might have lost him
all right uh congressman scott perry
thanks we'll watch where you'll play
this back and you'll see i did thank you
i wasn't rude
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight